hey everyone I cannot believe I'm saying
this but Jessica Jones season 2 is
finally here I'm Liana Galera I'm a
strossen and I got I hope you guys
watched our season 1 recap because right
now we just watched the first episode of
season 2 we're so hyped we were talking
about in the office everyone got a
little upset so pissed so we decided to
come in here and talk about it with you
guys so I guess it goes without saying
boiler alert okay we're gonna be
breaking down everything that happened
in the season 2 premiere plus our double
shots and hangovers so we're gonna be
telling you everything that we really
enjoyed everything that we really do not
want to see ever again
but I think we should kick things off
with our girl of the hour just a joke
Jessica freakin Jones yeah we pick
things back up with her and yes she is
you know what I actually really did love
about this episode if she is really
dealing with the fact that she killed
kill great yeah and this is a guy that I
mean I feel like in most superhero shows
are at pretty much any show when the
villain is killed everyone just kind of
moves on with their life but she's like
dealing with the repercussions of being
a murderer
it's really interesting I thought it was
really interesting it's also probably
because you know it feels like so long
ago that she killed kilgrave's but I
think it's just because we've waited so
long for this show to come back and a
half years she probably just killed
kilgrave teamed up with the defender
save New York City and now she's just
now getting a moment to breathe
it was feels long for us right but yeah
so we're really seeing her deal with
these repercussions and really seeing
that she and Trish are not in the best
of places
no because Trish is obviously doing
Trish talk which is her her show um but
she has no problem kind of talking about
Jessica and talking about everything
that's happened without dropping names
but what I do love is that it does take
place in this modern world where Jessica
is kind of like well anybody can do like
a quick Google search and be like Oh is
your one best friend sister you grew up
with right it's it doesn't take a
private investigator to realize that
you're talking about justice Trish
so Jessica Jones is taking on all these
clients that everyone knows that she's a
power person yeah and everyone feel
about power person as a term Hey
it's just it's kind of like saying
zombie in a movie it's like that
trademark thing you can't say mutant you
can't say this you can't say that yeah
they're just killing with power person
because I feel like they're like that's
what this is like well the gifted is now
taken as a title that's a power person
it's it's pretty lazy but yeah so
speaking of Trish you know we saw that
she has been talking on Trish talked me
else it's not that she has a new boo in
her life oh yeah
and it seems like things are pretty
serious as she must've been dating him
for a while yeah I hope she's a better
judge of character this time around then
he's very hot very attractive which
probably means but he's bad guy stop
right there yeah he also has the same
level if not more level of celebrity
than she does which I don't know if that
necessarily helps or hurts her like
demeanor right I can't imagine you know
dating someone that you're in the same
sphere as gonna butt heads a little bit
I imagine but you know so we saw that
Trish really is the one who's digging
into Jessica's past she is claiming that
it's because she really wants to see her
sister work through it but I definitely
think it's that she has these underlying
tones and wants to get better ratings
for her show and really wants to delve
into this like what is IgH hiding right
it's it's she's annoying me to some
person because she's trying to push
Jessica and I think it's ultimately
going to help her I think it's
ultimately a good thing but it does have
that underlying tone of like her trying
to get good ratings but one of the
things that she discovers is that
between the accident and when Jessica
ends up in a hospital bed there's 20
days that are unaccounted for and how
does she discover that by doing an
impromptu it's packed scene performance
which I loved
kissing oh come on it's Patsy but yeah
so I thought it was really interesting
that she got that news I also thought it
was really interesting and really
heartbreaking when she gave Jessica her
family's ashes right which like the
purpose of that was to what trigger her
to want to keep to find the answers
finally delve into her past an exception
reality
because it just felt a little cruel it
did feel cool it did feel cruel when
just I was like what is this like like
beat up Jessica day like I really felt
like that I and also on the flip side
though having your parents and storage
for 17 years maybe it was time to come
out I don't know everyone deals with
grief in a different way right um
Malcolm
I love Malcolm Malcolm Malcolm has now
adopted this he is now like Jessica's
unwanted protege yeah she keeps firing
him she wants him there but like keeps
pretending like she doesn't really want
a man fired exactly and I thought I was
really telling when Malcolm was helping
her clear up her brother's ashes which
was such a sweet moment she said he
would be your age now so almost you kind
of get that revelation that she looks at
Malcolm as like a pseudo younger brother
this is like over the last of us she's
kind of a duh yeah yeah so that's why
like she still wants him around she's
reluctantly like keeping him at arm's
length but you know she does she face
she has a kid brother relationship with
him exactly exactly
and it seems like Malcolm is actually
really starting to help with alias
investigations because we got a newbie
coming in trying to buy the firm price
Chang crashed Chang what that when he
comes in though he kind of he has like
that it's like a good offer yeah it's
like listen like you can work for me
mm-hmm um you can do you can like take
on whatever clientele you want yeah we
have total control and freedom and she's
not even willing to hear out the offer
yeah
immediately they're just become
adversaries which you realize like it's
a good thing she's stuck with her gut
because price Chang is actually working
secretly for dun dun dun hogarth which
girl is back mmm there she's she's she's
back she's winning awards um that she
bought herself but she bought herself
pam is now suing her yes
so things did not work out there
Mogar still sucks for now but the sad
thing is that should we do find out
she's sick we don't know to what extent
so we can't hang on there too much just
enough to where we can still feel okay
at night
she's a fictional character it's fine
but one of the things that I thought was
so great was that in season two we've
really got the introduction of other
more I was gonna say gifted people but
now I have to say powerful people with
the introduction of wizard I love wizard
I love wizard and wizard is a character
from the 6-1-6 Marvel Universe he it's
definitely not the same but it is in a
sense he's fast but it's fear-based
faster but you know if you're steeped in
that that will be a nice little bonus
for you that little Easter Egg Whizzer
but just as we were beginning to love
him he gets brutally crushed in a
accident yeah so Whizzer shows up keeps
saying there's something after him
we don't believe because there's a lot
of stories going into Jessica's alias
investigations and then she realizes
that he is telling the truth yeah he's
like a fear-based he only runs fast when
he's afraid like a bunny when he's
scared yes
so he gets really freaked out and like
runs away but down gets crushed by some
New York City scaffolding and something
is definitely after him yes I agree and
which could be our big bad of the season
I or it's just that IgH is trying to
cover up their tracks
because then Jessica I don't know how
she got to the IgH location that to me
was still a little confusing they looked
at the pills that someone had randomly
been sending wizard they traced it back
to a certain location in New York I
don't know apparently the locations
where they do experiments has been there
all along uh it was like a it was like a
front yes it was like a front and so she
walks through the hallways and what I
loved was that we got to see Jessica's
slowly starting to remember part of
those missing 20 days and them doing
experiments on there and then there's
moments where she says we were created
here yeah me wizard and something else
and we get a flash and we see this
creature a man yeah someone badly
scarred for a second I almost thought it
looked similar Deadpool yeah yeah
definitely I was thinking um I was
thinking the guy from Star Trek but that
obviously makes no sense but definitely
we got a little glimpse of that whether
or not that is gonna be our big bat of
the season I don't know
but I hopefully we
are gonna get answers and it won't take
too long em hmm this episode was
definitely a lot of setup yeah you can
tell that it's definitely building
towards something there was another new
character - there was Oscar her like
super Intendant bleep yeah and he um
I don't I'm not a fan he's very he's
very attractive
um Henschel love interest but he
definitely doesn't seem to like her when
he notices that she's using her her
powers he doesn't like that he
definitely seems to be well they're in
New York we've saw in season one like
some people who will do anything just to
eliminate people who are gifted and I
feel like he could be that type of
person yeah and he absolutely he's there
when wizard gets killed and Jessica's
there and he's like she's bad news I
want to be around her can you imagine if
you were to kick her out of their
apartment what is Jessica Jones without
that classic apartment oh my gosh she
probably is gonna really miss her stuff
oh yeah I can't run your business out of
here you can't do this you can't do that
so much to look forward to but here's
what I need to know right now Ashley yes
let's go through our double shots and
hangovers of this season two premiere
let's do it hit me with your double shot
aka something that you love I absolutely
loved with the wizard even though his
presence was very short-lived yeah I
thought it was really awesome to see you
know another character using powers I
really like the way it was done to the
way it was shot and the way it was
executed but um I I really hope that
they explore that a little more it was
like a nice little Easter egg I'm sad
he's gone so fast because he seemed like
a very delightful funny character but I
was definitely my favorite moment of the
episode was everything with him I love
that that's yours
I loved getting the fact that we are
finally finding out Jessica's origin
story you know normally with these
Netflix Marvel shows season one is their
origin story that was the case for iron
fist and Luke Cage and daredevil but
with Jessica Jones they just dropped us
into this kilgrave of it all which was
incredible baby Beth and it was so great
and so refreshing that I am glad and now
we're gonna start to get the other
puzzle pieces that we can see this giant
beautiful Jessica Jones picture and I
really enjoy the fact that we now have
little nuggets she was missing for 20
days she's found the location so we will
see where it leads us that's such a good
point to you with the origin story thing
because that's why that's why I love
spider-man homecoming some
yes we don't need a circle Ben because I
can we know it exactly not that we know
not that a lot of people know Jessica
Jones origin story but I thought that
was so nice
totally but so it's nice to flesh it out
a little bit which if we are still
talking about homecoming I would love to
see in the next one little flesh backs
more of to his high school life and
everything for sure yeah yeah your
hangover gosh you know I know this is
going to end up paying off but Trish
really really really bugged me in this
episode I just I didn't like her motives
I know she's trying to help Jess
ultimately but I felt like she was
pushing her too far trying to make her
accept this reality which it ultimately
does it makes her go to this IgH lab and
start investigating it but I just felt
like the the whole trying to get
readings which she admits to yeah was a
little it mostly at least she's owning
it at least she's not being sluicey yeah
trying to go behind that back I will
have a mini double shot maybe just a
single shot I did love that it's Patsy
moment I thought I loved back all back
to her childhood then that she was so
clearly ashamed yeah but as far as my
hangover the little bits of will Simpson
I know you find you cannot dance I know
and he's lurking and he's following
Trish and as much as we don't want to be
seeing her like act so awful as soon as
I see that she's being followed Betsy
worse yeah and and we'll well since it
now has like powers I guess and he's
following Trish around it's very
reminiscent of like what kilgrave was
doing yes with the black hood and like
is she seeing him is she not yeah I'm
not sure yeah I just I don't want him to
kill like Trish's boyfriend or something
which might happen he's very hot
something's gonna happen to him he's
either gonna be an awful human or he's
gonna die yeah yeah cuz that's what
happens all the attractive people and
Jessica Jones but we're gonna have to
find out what is coming up next because
we still have 12 more episode Oh should
watch them right now I think we should
but you guys can check back with us
because as soon as we are done binging
we're gonna be coming up for air and
discussing it all with you so keep it
locked or Twitter pages because we're
gonna be announcing when we're gonna be
having a big fan meetup so you can come
chat with us live about season 2 yes
we're gonna have a live chat where you
guys can talk about talk about
everything ask questions and we'll
answer everything and if there's
unless specifically wants to talk about
like Chuck them in the comments and
tweet us where we're happy to discuss
anything about season 2 that you guys
want to talk about awesome but until
then we'll see you guys soon and a
cheers Cheers
bye
[Laughter]